this should be the golden era for
Democrats right setting themselves up to
retake control of the House and Senate
from Republicans big league in 2018 the
White House in 2020 this should be a
time when Democrats can really take
advantage of the bumbling and disastrous
policy of the Trump White House combined
with these spineless Republicans mostly
unwilling to speak out against Donald
Trump at least so far but instead
Democrats have been bumbling themselves
and they're now announcing a totally
flaccid new slogan called a better deal
and I guess it's sort of a critique of
how Trump talks about making deals right
they're going to they're going to give
you a better deal than what the deal
maker himself is giving you but it just
feels totally vacuous and it already is
sort of conceding the concept of
deal-making to Donald Trump in saying
that they are doing more than just
opposing Trump by putting out this plan
the Democrats pick a name that already
concedes that it's about deals and it's
sort of a thinly veiled slide at Donald
Trump you're still sort of being just
not Trump when you choose a slogan
that's directly related to Donald Trump
but fine that's the sort of language of
it what about the substance the new
slogan is going to target issues like
job training programs and renegotiating
trade deals as well as promoting
specific spending plans for
infrastructure and a $15 minimum wage I
get it right Trump did well with one
idea make America great again Democrats
now want to do well with this idea a
better deal the the problem is that
you're conceding everything to Donald
Trump with this plan I criticize
Democrats for being Republicans light on
many issues on many issues Democrats are
genuinely different than Republicans but
looking look at the list here job
training programs okay hard to disagree
with job training programs but Trump has
been talking about job training for
people without college degrees who he
loves and now it becomes the Democratic
job training program versus the Trump
job training program you're already in
the weeds you've already lost when
that's one of the three to four points
that you pick renegotiating trade deals
that's a win for Trump if you're
relaunch is to pick up on something that
Trump has already been bamboozling
people about for 18 months
you've lost trade deals are obviously
important but people now care about them
without knowing a damn thing about them
because of how Donald Trump talks about
trade deals
it is a losers battle for Democrats now
to get involved in the trade deal game
and now Democrats say well we'll
renegotiate them that's exactly what
Trump wants to do Democrats now need to
explain again in the weeds
how will they renegotiate trade trade
deals better than Trump you can't win
with that a plan for infrastructure
spending Trump campaigned on that yes it
was a total crony capitalist version of
infrastructure spending but again to win
moderate now you've got to get into the
weeds how will we do infrastructure
spending versus how does Trump want to
do infrastructure spending Chuck Schumer
is trying to have the right idea on this
but it's pretty lukewarm he said over
the weekend when you lose to somebody
who has 40% popularity you don't blame
other things Comey Russia you blame
yourself so what did we do wrong people
didn't know what we stood for just that
we were against Trump and still believe
that so yeah okay Schumer is right you
should be blaming yourself that's the
right instinct but it's not just that
people didn't know what you stood for
you stood for lots of confusing and weak
things now in comes Nancy Pelosi she's
way off the mark okay Nancy Pelosi said
to the hill on July 23rd or according to
the hill on July 23rd House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi also told the
newspaper that Democrats are not looking
for a course correction but rather a
presentation correction no no no
Americans are looking for a course
correction away from corporate Democrats
that on too many issues are
indistinguishable from Republicans yes
they need a course correction Pat Nancy
Pelosi is completely wrong here about
this
yes the other problem with this slogan
too is it just looks like you're going
for half-measures again it's a better
deal it's not the best deal and
Democrats have been screwed by this
before I mean when we talk about the
minimum wage it's never really about
making the minimum wage a living wage as
it is you know let's say ten dollars is
good enough for 12 dollars good enough
we talk about health care you know we
just concede this idea of universal
health care and we settle on maybe the
public option well that doesn't work out
because you have to negotiate and you
find yourself somewhere in the middle if
you seek out a whole loaf of bread you
may get half a loaf of bread if you just
seek out half a loaf of bread you may
not get much you might get it from lice
you might get just the crust
what should Democrats actually do
comprehensive United message on health
care ok top issue according to gallops
biggest problem poll it's a very good
poll take a position like Medicare for
all or take a position on really a
robust public option even though that
arguably was it was too weak a starting
point for the Obama care debate
something specific that isn't just
slightly different than what Republicans
are offering fix student loans and deal
with college costs in some real way top
issue for voters as of this month is the
economy in general as well as
unemployment and jobs 14 percent of
Americans believe that those two issues
together are the most important problem
you've got to do something serious their
immigration is still cited as a very
important issue it's not totally clear
that people are voting on that people
will vote on health care people will
vote on the economy and by the way the
actual top issue according to Gallup 19%
dissatisfaction with government and poor
leadership a trump light slogan about a
better deal than Trump will give you is
not going to change that I'm sorry you
also have to get everyone on the same
page when it comes to their talking
points so you send out Democratic
surrogates politicians on all the cable
news outlets and have them repeat the
same things that's what Republicans are
good at so you know for example when it
comes to this idea of repealing
Obamacare make sure it gets known to the
American public that 43,000 people a
year will die needlessly if the ACA is
repealed it's sadly patte not looking
great for 2018 I mean it's like we
barely even started and it's
ready not looking good this is I'm very
concerned about this quote new direction
from Democrats